let's see if we can write three-fifths
as a decimal I encourage you to pause
this video and think about if you can do
it on your own and I'll give you a hint
here can we rewrite this fraction so
instead of it being in terms of fifths
it can be in terms of tenths so I'm
assuming you've given a go at it let's
try to write this as let's try to
rewrite this as a fraction with 10 as
the denominator but let's just first
visualize this so we have fifths so that
is one so let's let's say that's 1/5 let
me just copy and paste this so copy and
paste
that is two fists that is 3/5 and that
is four ffice and that is 5/5 or if this
would be a whole now so that is our
whole and we want to color in three of
those five so we want to think about
what 3/5 are so let me get my magenta
out
so that's 1/5 I can actually make this
bigger even two-fifths and 3/5 there you
go
color that in that is 3/5 now how could
I write this in terms of tenths instead
of 3/5 a certain number of tenths well
let's split this whole into tenths and
the easiest way to split this whole into
tenths is to take each of those fifths
and turn them into two tenths so let's
do that so if we were to just if we were
to do this right over here we now have
twice as many sections so another way of
thinking about it we are taking we are
multiplying the number of sections by
two we now have ten sections each of
these is 1/10 and the three of those
sections are now going to be twice as
many what we have in magenta we now have
twice as many sections in magenta so
we're going to multiply that by 2 as
well notice we just multiplied the
numerator and the denominator by two but
hopefully it makes conceptual sense
every piece when we're talking about
fifth we have now doubled so that
instead
of everyone v is now 2 is now 2/10 you
have a 1/10 now and a 1/10 now and we
could just keep writing 1 tens if we
like each of these each of these things
right over here are a tenth and so and
then each of the three are now twice as
many tenths so the 3/5 is now 6/10 so
let's write that down so this is going
to be equal to 6 over 10 6 over 10 now
why is this interesting
you can literally view this as 6/10 so
you could literally view this as 6 let
me write it this way 6 times 1/10 6
times 1/10 I'm going to do that in blue
6 times 1/10 well what's another way to
represent 6/10 or 6 times 1/10 well you
can express that as a decimal where we
go to the tenths place so when you write
a decimal so let's see zero point the
space the the place right to the right
of the decimal that is the tenths place
this right over here is the ones that
right over here is the tenths that's the
tenths place so how many tens do we have
we have six tenths so we could write
this as zero point six so there you have
it let me write that this is equal to
this is equal to zero point six and
we're done
we've just expressed this as a decimal 6
tenths is the same thing as six tenths
which can be re-written as three-fifths
or vice versa